donc ils ont voulu faire croire aux
techniques venus d'une autre planète
dont ils ont fait des expériences ou ça
vous l'avez jamais dit non complètement
tonus jamais mis à part ça qu'on
applaudisse ligori gage de bonheur est
ce que tu sais combien il ya d'énergie
grâce à le gall mc carey dans ses
entrailles de billets alors simple
feuille
ils volent au vent alain laurent albert
lemant et bien il y a huit fois et c'est
sérieux ces scientifiques il ya huit
fois l'énergie de la bombe atomique
d'hiroshima dratel on aura question pour
un menton
[Rires]
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est une mallette ça c'est une manette
c'est soit c'est de l'eau sage il fait
toujours beau alors cette manette votre
mal et cette manette vous déjà trois
cent mille euros elle toute seule
berne et thoune à 300 millions de latour
lafite rothschild am voilà tu imagine
mal mais c'est vrai mais quel est le
gars qui va aller braquer les bogdanoff
vous êtes un bras câble il faut pas
bouger un faux pas bougé pas ça prend
les clients
attention ça prend les têtes ça variés
un là et de temps qu'il le calcul tac ça
va arriver dans un instant là on essaie
de faire une prouesse technique au dire
quelque chose qui ne sera jamais refait
à la télévision française on l'a on n'a
pas fait les mêmes études d'abord ça
c'est l'accord pourtant moi j'ai fait
sciences po paris attention j'ai sorti
lauréats étaient sorties blu-ray à 2
science n'ont pas battu devait avoir le
menton fille raconte
[Musique]
pourquoi guns & carry amel d'attention à
la bouteille de coca et fo ainsi 33 pas
du tout ses 33 cm je mets là dedans en
europe devrait être ça fait longtemps
qu'on n'a pas vu intentions ont consenti
vie pourquoi ton sortie net parce que 30
cm pour ceux de provence centilitres
attention attention l'expérience et
l'énergie égale mars voilà la masse
pourrait la transformer l'énergie est
devenu magique
et voilà avec l'évacuer on évacue et
maintenant elle devenue énergie pu et
pour pouvoir la vitesse de la lumière
parce que quand un objet se transforme
en énergie va pleurer des liens non plus
allez-y le menton fier dit quoi dans
l'oreille aller au débat ça marche pas
donc ils ont voulu faire part aux
techniques venus d'une autre planète
donc ils ont fait des expériences ou ça
vous ne l'avez jamais dit quoi l'être
antonius jamais ce que peut vous
l'offrir igor et grichka revient sûr de
voir si avec ça vous fait un pari menton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]